i am raghavindran bioinformatics mentor
and research consultant with omix logic
let me brief you a little bit about my
background on research interests i am a
computational biologist by training and
i specialize in the subjects like
multi-omics data analysis and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein social bioinformatics i
completed my formal education in
biophysics and bioinformatics and then
graduated phd in computational biology
from max bank institute germany then
i worked on projects in the institute of
bioinformatics and applied biotechnology
in bengaluru and java media university
as a postdoctoral research scientist
over throughout my research career i
developed special interests
and expanded my expertise in precision
anthology through data science methods
that is applied to several multi-org
data so right throughout this career
right from my phd period i have had the
fortunate
experience to mentor
different undergraduate students and
enjoy the experience immensely so i feel
very much privileged to work with some
of the bright young minds like you all
in the past and also in the future i
wish and i hope you all to enjoy as much
as i do in this partnership between
amity noita and fine biotech university
now let me briefly
speak about one of my research projects
on precision oncology so i just
okay it's doing okay i chose to speak uh
specifically about this study because it
utilizes a pipeline of very well
established multi-omics data analysis
methods on publicly available data so i
hope at the end of this uh
a small dem
talk
this project will inspire you all to
develop your own scientific curiosity
leveraging the abundance of data that
are publicly available
so uh
i think you all had a very good
introduction about what cancer is and
how that is the leading cause of deaths
disease deaths worldwide so for such a
dreadful disease a systematic cancer
treatments have relied on
chemotherapeutic drugs that are
marginally more toxic to cancer cells
than normal cells
this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percent of
the cancer patients responds to cancer
treatments and in comparison about 80
percent of the patients will respond
positively to popular painkillers that
are available in the market so a
prominent solution to this problem is
precision oncological therapy where a
treatment strategy is designed by
targeting the molecular characteristics
of the patient's tumor
hence the treatment is personalized to
the patients who are likely to respond
positively to specific cancer therapies
unfortunately there is not enough data
from cancer patients to molecularly
characterize all the tumors under
multitude of different treatment options
hence we have to resort to a suitable
model system to predict tumor responses
to several treatments
so we have already covered why we have
to do this and let me straight away go
to how
the tumor cells from cancer patients are
subjected to next-gen sequencing
techniques and the information about the
gene expression gene mutation and
epigenetic variation were extracted this
data molecularly characterizes the
tumors these tumor samples in the are
then grafted into immunosuppressed mouse
and administered several cancer drugs
then the treat the tumors response to
these respective drugs are documented
this data tells us about the tumor's
reaction to different treatments
both the molecular characterization data
and the treatments response data are
available along with the publication
such a wealth of data generates a
plethora of research questions
i use this data to design and implement
machine learning models to predict tumor
responses to different treatments that
are available
so what did we find we found that the
treatment response could be predicted
more accurately when we use data from
multiple genes compared to traditional
single gene biomarkers and the accuracy
of such prediction can be increased
immensely with more than one type of
sequencing data such as the gene
expression or the gene mutation or the
copy number variation data was used to
train the machine learning models
so that is what is depicted here as we
go from left to right the information
content increases first this method uses
only a single gene biomarker and the
accuracy which which
is supposed to be close to one is
scattered all around the scale but when
we increase the information content to
multiple genes and supplement that with
several other
sequencing data like gene mutation data
and copy number variation data the
accuracy tremendously increases and the
consistency also increases so what more
could be done with this data a gene set
enrichment analysis
on the on the set of most informative
genes from these models can be performed
to identify specific biomarkers for the
tumors response to different
treatment regimes
one can also extend such an analysis to
include patient data from the tcga
repository and these yeah
these supports are currently carried out
are being carried out by my partners in
the jain year so i hope this was very
informative and inspiring for you all to
generate interesting research questions
on the data that are publicly available
so i see that you had an excellent
introduction to the platform that is
comics logics and now i want to
provide you a sample of how the lessons
involving coding is organized on this
platform the courses that involve coding
a small assembly of courses that are
involved coding are given in this slide
and they're all designed and directed
specifically towards students who have
completed the introductory courses in
their respective subjects so all these
courses have the following structure and
in the part that involve executing r or
python codes so these lessons include
what analysis are we doing why are we
doing such an analysis
and what do we expect to learn from such
an analysis and finally how to do such
an analysis the codes themselves as
given in as given in an example here
are include themselves include
sufficient explanatory comments at each
step so it is very easy to follow and
finally when the output is generated
from performing such an analysis
and we also give and we also give a
brief uh account on how to interpret
this analysis or how to interpret the
results of such an analysis with respect
to the biological question at hand
so
this is how the coding lessons involving
coding are handled in the
platform that you'll be are about to
enjoy
so so many students congregating at one
place would naturally precipitate into
even into an evolution of interesting
science student clubs so sciomics club
is one such initiative taken by all the
students associated with time biotech
the goal of this club is to help fellow
students to to learn about bioinformatic
research using our via group sessions
and easy to take courses and debates and
discussion this club welcomes students
from all the fields of life sciences and
is not limited to anybody who has an
introduction to bioinformatics or any
such computational biology so
these students will meet together and
learn from and with each other so they
have this this club has definitive
topics of interest every month and based
on this topic two guest speakers are
invited to talk on the topics of the
month which is then followed by short q
a focused on the role of bioinformatics
and some carrier prospects for today's
students and there are specific
instructions on how to join and be part
of this club in the omixlogic platform
website and overall
i would like you all to know that i will
be talking in detail as a guest speaker
on this club this saturday that is
november 20. i